[Applause]
if you guys haven't seen it already i'd
be shocked but there's a youtuber named
mr beast yeah now mr beast is probably
the biggest person on youtube right now
yeah he puts out videos they get 40 50
60 million views it's insane it's
unbelievable
guys incredibly talented
he recreated squid game
the south korean
horror
drama whatever you want to call it uh
anthology that was on netflix he
basically recreated spent 3.5 million
dollars had 456 people come out to
compete in squid game obviously not to
the death they lose they just get taken
out of the potential money the person
who won it won 456 thousand dollars yeah
he spent three and a half million
recreating each one of the stages i
think he did it in north carolina he has
like a guess a big sound stage there
and um
it's on youtube you could go watch it
and i thought it was absolutely
brilliant to see it executed incredible
it was brilliant to see it executed
it
yeah yeah i mean it was just it's to see
something that scale was unbelievable so
impressive yeah yo mr beast is like a
real life social media great gatsby okay
like he's just this guy that popped up i
don't know how the [__] he made all his
money
but all of a sudden you just keep
hearing about him and he's doing all
this really cool [__] and it's like it's
like the that [__] squid game thing
is the party that you got to be at bro
here's the thing
this guy has been i know it sounds so
crazy to say this because he's
so much more um
has so much more awareness than we do
but i'm gonna say it as i feel it he's
been on my radar for a while right right
now he should be on my radar he's the
most successful person on youtube but
what he does is he does these like
incredible like games yes and they're
not all games competition but it's just
like i'm going to stay underground for
24 hours or i'm going to stay under
water for 24 hours he does these videos
and you're just like okay i got to see
where this goes it's really good you
watch it the editing's great his crew is
all really good it's fun
now the beauty of this squid game thing
that has received probably over a
hundred million views so 130 as of now
130. okay
what happened when he was doing those
things on youtube
but this is also on youtube but they
were tapping into the youtube community
but if you're not someone who watches
youtube regularly you can have no clue
who mr beast is because he's not doing
things that are going to get picked up
by the news you know if you're just like
a complete casual when it comes to
youtube the daily news isn't talking
about it the los angeles times didn't
talk about it late night's not talking
about it it doesn't tap into mainstream
culture right and i think something
really interesting about the squid game
one is now there's a lot of people
that all of a sudden are going to learn
about the most popular person on youtube
yes they're going to quote-unquote
discover
the most successful man on the internet
which is a crazy thing to say but it is
in a microcosm what is happening now
with fame right he's the most famous
person on youtube but outside of youtube
if you're not someone that watches
youtube regularly you will have no clue
who this person is but because he tapped
into something topical
everybody comes to the watering hole for
topicality right if you're talking about
a specific issue we got to indulge in it
if it's about something i care about i
got to go tap in even if i'm not
someone's on youtube my mom might not
even be on youtube but if she wants to
you know see a reaction to squid game
she's gonna go in there for the
conversation and i wonder if he starts
to bring topicality into his future
endeavors because he sees
the
3x reaction that you got from doing yeah
what do you think and i wonder if it's a
yeah i think so and i wonder if that's
going to
start the trend of a lot of people
trying to do this but i'm not sure if
they can compete with him on scale yeah
scale and money and even like creativity
like he really understands it seems that
he really understands youtube how to
make it work but i'm just wondering if
if he starts to go oh wow this is how i
cross over to mainstream now i'm a
creator that happens to create on
youtube before this
i was a youtuber yeah and that's the
difference maker when you go mainstream
you're just using youtube as a platform
you just happen to be a creative and
this was a story i saw in news outlets
somebody created a squid game spent
three and a half million dollars so i
think this could be
the way he crosses over like you said i
think this is the beginning of it now he
just feeds it and feeds it and feeds it
what do you think mark it's just funny
just like that the news is described as
like somebody mm-hmm you know what i
mean like which it he is i guess
somebody to like the whole world even
like america but on youtube he's like
such a presence so i think what he'll
probably do is tap into pop culture as
it presents itself but the issue with
that is you just make yourself dependent
on pop culture so like with what he's
doing and like his content is if you're
doing a stunt based on pop culture and
there's nothing really poppy in the news
then you're like oh crap what do i do so
i think he's just going to continue on
his own thing and then anytime something
pops up yeah and he doesn't need to do
it every week right he only needs to do
it when he wants these bumps but there's
been a huge bump i mean earlier you were
telling me he was averaging like between
half a million to a million subscribers
a week that were added to his channel
yeah and he did this and he got seven
million yeah according to like some uh
like social blade or something like that
that's what it looked like i mean that's
unreal yeah but that's what happens when
you tap into the masses then you get the
news outlets start talking about it and
all of a sudden you go from a youtuber
to a famous person yes but and again
this is something that like slapped me
in the face when i was in l.a doing a
movie when i was there and i was like oh
these people only care about movies yeah
they got no clue what we're doing over
here yeah and
he i'm sure is abundantly aware that i'm
sure he's walking around walmart and all
the kids there going holy [__] you're
the most famous person on the planet and
all the people working there or maybe
another people working there but like
the senior executives are going who is
this person that they want to take
pictures yeah he said he's having like a
hard time like working with like tv
studios i was listening to him on a
podcast recently he was like yeah i'm
having a tough time because it's like
i'm trying to work with tv studios or
like in the past he was yeah and they'd
be like eh we don't really see it like
blah blah blah like the money it doesn't
really make sense like you know we won't
give you more money he's like i'm
getting 10 times the views you're
getting on any show you're doing like
per dollar spent like you guys don't
understand they don't but to that point
like industry stuff i don't think they
see it
but he only took two or three of these a
year max yeah of course just enough to
like tap in to that to that exact point
it's like
and and i and i i remember either i was
talking to you about this or i was
looking into it about him just going all
in on youtube
and um it's a fascinating case study
because like trying to get these tv
people like trying to convince them of
something that you already know that
works while their
ship is sinking
is a really
awful task yeah well it's it's actually
interesting it's like the amazon thing
okay that most of these businesses fail
because in order to
succeed you have to do something to kill
your current business
you know what i mean like so amazon
starts going to like digital ebooks yeah
when their whole business is selling
physical books
so they hire someone and they go yo your
job is to put your old job out of
business the iphone killed the ipod and
they were like what and they're like
yeah you have to innovate to where your
new thing is destroying the old thing
which takes a lot of confidence that one
the new thing is gonna be the new thing
yeah and the faith that like you're
going to be able to actually do it
effectively yeah it's really scary
blockbuster is in the same situation
they just chose not to do it like if we
stream we're going to kill all of our
retail stores but if you want to survive
you have to change to continue to
innovate which sounds like a really easy
little thing to say like oh yeah if you
want to survive just change but it's
like that's a really terrifying position
to be yeah but imagine how pissed off
you would be
like you get 50 million views
on average right yeah you're talking to
a network that can barely get a million
views for a sitcom that they're spending
tens of millions of dollars on
you get 50 million views yeah film and
[__] with your friends with the homies
yeah yeah right you know how to film it
you know how to make it very and it's
clean
yeah yeah right it's like super purses
you could put any advertising on it
right and you're sitting down with these
execs and they're going i don't know if
i get it who the [__] are you yeah no
you don't get it yeah you don't that's
why your business is failing you don't
get what people are actually watching i
don't even know if they know their
business is failing it's crazy
yeah because you're the last one to know
you fell off yeah kind of like you know
how like a rapper is the last one yeah
yeah they're not popping anything yeah
and i wonder if that's the execs because
it's also like willful ignorance you're
like i don't want to oh no this is just
a down time yeah and we'll come back up
we'll get a new show we'll get popping
again you know sometimes you have a few
bad seasons yeah or you look at all your
peers you're like oh we were competing
with all these other tv companies and
they're all going down they're like
they're we're we're about where all the
rest of the tv
forget who you're competing with your
survival is still on the line though
yeah yeah yeah 100 but you're like oh
yeah abc is doing this nbc is doing this
you don't realize that oh i'm not
competing with tv anymore i'm competing
with this whole new thing yeah it's just
eyeballs yeah yeah who is getting the
eyeballs who's catching eyeballs and
this kid knows how to do it and he has a
he's on the marketplace for the eyeballs
too and the savvy [__] he did he had a
big ad in the middle of it to make his
money but even just like you know they
had the little packs whenever they got
eliminated that would explode in the
actual squid game show they died he even
strategically put in somebody like a few
people overacting like oh oh oh and then
he looked in the camera goes it doesn't
hurt it was just like hey guys remember
this is for everybody this is all in
good fun yeah and the actual squid game
they never played
the last game in the squid game show is
the game called squid game but that's
too violent so he's like oh we're just
going to do musical chairs with the
squiddy and he told he said it when i
watched he was just like
none of us know the rules to this [__]
yeah koreans live in america yeah yeah
yeah i was fired because i honestly they
got to that last one i was like i don't
even want to deal with all this and then
when he said musical chairs i was like
that's my boy right there yeah yeah
that's how we do it
i'm saying whatever the the explanation
aside i think the reason it is like this
can be too violent we can't have people
hurting each other like this has got to
be as harmless as possible so everybody
can view it he's not thinking about a
million views right he's thinking about
a billion views right so it has to be a
much squeakier clean thing to get a
billion views yeah yeah it was just it
was really interesting i'm curious to
see his trajectory he's got to do more
topical [__] because it's hard to it's
hard to step away from the views like
once you taste 100 yeah and you know why
yeah it's not like it happened you're
like oh this was a mistake i don't know
how to recreate this you know exactly
how yeah
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be hard
when that new you know spider-man movie
that everybody wants to see and they're
spending ten thousand dollars a ticket
coming out it's gonna be hard to be like
i made my own webbing and i climbed a
building yeah yeah like it's going to be
hard to not do that knowing you're going
to get 100 million right
that video would be fire
i'm going to be spider-man like so far
jumping off buildings and swinging yeah
that's fine you got to watch it yeah i
want 10 beast
you know what i mean and if you only
knew what going beast meant oh yeah yeah
yeah we got our own beast over here that
video yeah that video is guaranteed 200
million the real mr beast
that's guaranteed 250 million views yeah
well i don't i think they have a view of
those videos already they don't get 250
million views but uh if they were on
youtube yeah and depending on the animal
if it was like a redhead and they've had
a cool thumbnail i've had a cool
thumbnail and an engaging uh intro
engaging intro cool thumbnail and
brought to you by adult video game yeah
fair enough that's the truth the right
thumbnail you might think
you just take a break from [__] the
animal just put a carrot in this mouth
this episode of going beast is brought
to you by brawl game
[Laughter]
when you're done [__] animals you can
play this with your other friends who
have never had sex
yo
that'd actually be good brand synergy
yeah
wrong yeah yeah now we're thinking now
we're thinking yeah when mr beast comes
out you gotta explain to him what now we
gotta get him on you gotta explain what
we're going beast means we gotta yeah
we'll talk about what going b's for sure
but we gotta get him on i'm also just
curious about what drives them
like
is it is it truly fun is it all outcome
dependent or is it truly fun to do these
things is the journey also fun
yeah that's a good question because i
think he tries to make it fun but at a
certain point the numbers are so big you
have to be very outcome focused yeah
yeah you have to be outcomes and then
you probably lose some of the fun yeah
so i'm curious it's like and then if a
video doesn't do well for him
is it not enjoyable like does he it
seems like a lot of the ones i've
watched like he suffers through
suffering is part of it yeah yeah you
bury yourself or whatever yourself i'm
not gonna leave this circle for 24 hours
you know it's like survive on an island
like all these things are suffering
and it's worth that outcome but if that
outcome wasn't there would this still be
stuff you do with your friends would it
be these cool pranks that you would do
on a saturday when you're not working
right and we're in this like
real position of luxury where like we
enjoy the [__] out of what we do yes
we're on stage we're doing a podcast
like this is enjoyable and then the fact
that we can monetize it is just that's
some god i don't know someone looking
out for us yeah you know so i'm always
focused on these people and like what
it's like for him to see a video do 20
million views and be mad yeah
yeah all right guys this exclusive
patreon clip is provided by the best
underwear in the business and that is
culprit i do not wear another pair of
underwear you will never see me again
wearing another pair of underwear it is
beyond the best pair of underwear that
you will ever wear in your life i
promise you this you should try it you
should try it immediately and matter of
fact if you go to culpritunderwear.com
and use the code flagrant at checkout
you're going to get 25
off that is a special holiday sale so
make sure you go do that immediately
this company is run by our boys okay
it's run by our people our family okay
these are [__] we trust and
they give us the best goddamn product on
the planet i'm not bullshitting you
right now the best pair of underwear
you've ever worn in your life this was
going to happen you're going to order
one and you're going to go oh wow that's
how i want my dick balls and butt to
feel for the rest of my life and then
you just keep on ordering them so that's
what i would recommend now if you
understand what i'm saying and you trust
me you probably just order a bunch but
if you don't you order one and then
you'll be like you know what schultz
said you were right and you go back to
culpritunderwear.com use that code
flagrant at checkout and get 25 off for
that holiday sale now let's get back to
this exclusive patreon clip you can get
the full episode at patreon.com flagrant
too what do you think about them cuomo's
my boys
what i don't think it's a big deal talk
to me all right so i'll take our
comments so here's what i'm reading
he's advising miles why you already
looking so dis disconcerted
he's already so he just basically
advised his brother and he was like hey
here's the deal what do you need from me
i want to help i want to help my brother
out of a jam isn't that what we would
all do yeah so here's the thing there's
one thing into this [__] up but go
ahead go go go go there's one thing he
did that's [__] up that he apparently
sent a text message that said like i've
got a lead on the wedding girl which in
for uh
whatever it's about uh some girl at a
wedding that said andrew cuomo like
sexually harassed her at a wedding yeah
so that text is a little bit [__] up
to me because i don't know what the
intention is behind i've got a lead on
the wedding girl yeah but the other
thing that he did that everybody's so
upset about is he asked other
journalists if they knew if a story was
dropping about his brother yeah we would
all do that so here's the thing two
things can be true the cuomo's can be
absolute scumbags and their dynasty can
be falling apart and never to be uh you
know recreated ever again and
we would have all done the exact same
thing to help our brother yes
i think the issue with the cuomo
specifically is this like go you're not
in your head it's like basking in the
sunshine yeah you're doing the [__] [__]
that everybody it's like when a priest
rapes a kid it's like it's more
egregious than when just like a random
guy does it at a bus stop yeah cause
it's like oh you're supposed to be the
pinnacle of morality like you're telling
everyone how to live and you're telling
everyone how to be virtuous a politician
and
a newscaster yeah a journalist like we
have to trust both of you to do the
right thing and to be the right people
and then not only is he a journalist but
he's a journalist that's positioned in a
way either through his own doing or the
doing of the institution he's a part of
that rallies against you know men that
are acting toxic and problematic men
yeah that's funny and government
corruption yeah yeah like if there's a
right-wing guy that does this people are
like uh you know like but andrew to me
is a slimy [__] yeah chris chris is not
corrupt he's just italian italians love
their families the defense didn't work
for andrew andrew but if andrew cuomo to
be specific but if chris cuomo was like
dude i'm not corrupt i'm just italian we
love our families
which the italian defense is so funny
the italian defense for family works
great that's exactly all mafia is his
family well that's what he said when he
was touching the girls he was like i'm
not i wasn't touching i wasn't being
creepy i'm italian yeah that's what i'm
saying for anything
that doesn't work for chris
it does work bro it does work just say
you're italian yeah it works out okay
i'm gonna try this no i mean i'm not
saying that like for example like
okay
let's say an immigrant just came from
like a refugee just came from i'm trying
to think of a place
where were all the refugees in europe
from
when remember they had to teach them how
to not rape you know remember that they
gave them not rape classes and [__]
i don't know but basically some places
where they weren't used to women just
walking around bikinis and [__] yeah
right and they had to be like yo over
here you can't you know rape these girls
put the stone down yeah exactly yeah put
this stone down right yeah so they had
to teach them how to do it now if a guy
just started whistling as a girl at a
girl as they walked by
and they were a refugee you'd be like
ugh he don't know any better it's that
soft bigotry [__] it's like yeah in his
country if a girl walks by in a bikini
she's trying to get raped so that's why
he's acting like that you got to educate
them you can't do that [__] you know i
mean like i'll be honest like my boxing
coach said this [__] to me he's like yo
in egypt
if a guy's looking at your girl it's
because he's trying to [__] your girl if
a guy looks at my girl in america i
don't care it's like people look at
girls here people have conversations
with them it's no big deal you say hi
you get some coffee but in egypt that
means something different yeah so it's
like look at a wolf in his eyes boom so
if i see a guy doing that in egypt i
gotta cut his head open with a knife
there's some countries
men hold hands in some countries that's
and exactly over here that means
something yo
that's true so it's like you know this
goes both ways culture changes so the
italian thing kind of does work an old
italian dude kissing a girl whatever
like that i get it yeah that is it
all right i don't agree but it worked
for chris for sure and if there's
something that we let old italian men's
no no touching i don't think it works
for andrew cuomo who's the [__]
governor like you're not some just
italian uncle yeah i mean you're the
[__] governor of the italian uncle
if he had the opportunity to be
president nobody would have an issue
with this
i don't think anybody's talking about i
think it'd be more like and i'm not
trying to call out these chicks but i
think it'd be more like hey remember
that time we met at the party and we had
such a great conversation you don't
remember that instead of remember that
time you kissed me twice and you said
something that was a little
inappropriate
but i think once you see a sinking ship
it's like yo it's time to pile on baby
let me get this cloud up yeah maybe yeah
i i don't believe it's strong enough to
argue to the death i just think it
doesn't necessarily work for andrew
cuomo as governor of new york yeah as
just some regular old italian sure but
for chris cuomo i actually think there
is some room to be like doug this is my
brother
okay he did some [__] [__] but that's my
you're always gonna hold down your
brother yeah any of us would have done
the exact same thing it's still wrong he
can't use the italian excuse now because
if i'm chris i'd be pissed i should be
pissed off i never took that [__] bro
the reason i did this because i'm
actually italian and you are to use the
italian thing on the thing you can't use
it on
yeah what am i supposed to say i can't
be like oh i'm also italian that's why i
defended my family
he's like you were touching these girls
you said this because you're italian
idiot yo but when would you stop
when would you stop like when would you
go yo i can't hold my brother down with
that murder rape
yeah like uh molestation any of that
[__] that umbrella no everything short
of that let's go sexual and even murder
what's the context
about sexual assault
with the boys yeah what if he goes beast
sexually assaulting an animal what if he
goes beast what what if your boy goes
beast he goes beast that's between him
and the animals
your brother you walk into your brother
those beasts don't have a [__] a pig
hey hey jesus what if he's happy what
was your dog jesus i don't [__] happy
now
yeah that's that's where he draws that's
my dog yeah come on if anybody [__]
happy is me what if he's using it hey my
[__] my dog is me as a shake weight
he's just got happy he's holding happy
by the abdomen yeah and he's just
[__] yeah yeah yeah he's doing a
pellets on workout class yeah at the
same time like 10 more minutes
[Music]
that's my dog anybody [__] happy's
mouth
i'm happy and you hear like happy
barking but also like gagging
let me ask you this
let me ask you this do the bark sound
happy they sound so happy you see the
tail wagging crazy
you gotta warm it up dude you always
gotta do some foreplay before you go
straight beast are you talking about
going straight beast without getting
that [__] top
you know it's the most sloppy top if
it's coming from a beast you're gonna
turn down hold on you would turn down
the sloppiest top of all
dog top i guess yeah
wow
put some peanut butter in your ass no i
didn't get
when you're when you're doing your thing
well when i'm beating yeah and i'm
beating down yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
think i'm [__]
why don't you flip her over
dick
you know what i'm saying with the lippy
anyway so yeah your dog just gets
[__] throated
hey if happy enjoys it good for them
happy enjoys a good friend whatever
makes happy happy right what are you
saying you're saying free chris
i'm saying free chris dead ass all right
i'm saying free christmas [__] chris
yeah but he ain't not for this but not
for this but not for the exactly but not
for this i don't think he did anything
wrong here but his brother did rape
women allegedly he did something wrong
but you just would also do the wrong
thing what he grew up with women
no yeah
i think he graped him
that's groping rape i know where'd he
great what's that where's the raped him
where's the
ape part coming from where's the ape
he graped him
it's a rapist it's a groping rape
he raped him with a grope c son if you
said some [__] like that to me i would
legit be like come on dog he's just
italian they're dead
and what do they love
didn't like it one bit
didn't like it one bit but she didn't
whine immediately she took a little time
she let it make a great need
a grape needs a little time to become a
wine yeah and in italian you shouldn't
understand that yeah yeah italia should
know better yeah and maybe six to seven
years i'm gonna get a wine a wine from
96. at least today was my best year that
was the best year the dude was on a roll
he was graping everything what up people
you just watched a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [__] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace